alors que le canada enregistre l'une de
ses meilleures performances en matière
de création d'emplois en 42 ans donc
avec un taux de chômage de 5,6 pour sa
olivier on peut dire que l'année se
termine bien autant au pays que dans
plusieurs provinces
exactement et l'année s'est terminée
sous le signe de la stabilité christine
avec les données qui ont été publiés
pour le mois de décembre on regarde sans
détails
alors le taux de chômage au canada qui
est demeuré stable à 5 et 6 dixièmes
pour cent il ya eu création de 9300
emplois
pour ce qui est du québec le taux de
chômage a grimpé d'un dixième de point à
5 5%
il ya eu création de 3700 emplois alors
pourquoi le taux de chômage grec même si
la création d'emplois c'est parce que la
population active c'est à dire la
population en âge de travailler a quand
même fortement augmenté au cours du mois
de décembre
maintenant du côté de l'alberta il ya
seize mille 900 emplois qui ont été
perdus ce qui fait que le taux de
chômage a bondi d'un dixième de point à
6,4 pour cent
les secteurs qui ont connu les
meilleures performances il ya notamment
le secteur de la fabrication
il ya aussi le secteur de l'entreposage
et du transport il ya des pertes
d'emplois pendant qu'ils ont été
observées dans les secteurs de la vente
au détail et de la vente de gros et avec
ces données du mois décembre on peut
faire le bilan de 2018
une bonne année effectivement pour ce
qui est de l'emploi cent soixante trois
mille emplois qui ont été créés au pays
une hausse de 9 dixièmes de point je
parle dans les années antérieures
avaient été meilleurs en 2016 y avait eu
une hausse de 1 2% de l'emploi et
croissance de l'emploi assez
exceptionnel en 2017 qui avait été de
2,3 pour cent chez nos voisins
américains on a également publié des
données sur le chômage et sur l'emploi
aujourd'hui robuste création d'emplois
312 1000 postes ont été créés aux états
unis le taux de chômage qui s'est établi
à 3,9 pour cent
bon voila et puis amour sur les marchés
boursiers parce qu'il ya ça a été
difficile
oui c'était plutôt difficile hier on a
enregistré de nombreuses baisses alors
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya un
rebond aujourd'hui rebond qui notamment
causé par ces bonnes données sur
l'emploi qui ont été publiés aux états
unis est également l'annoncent d'une
ronde de pourparlers entre washington et
pékin dans le but parvenir un accord
commercial alors on regarde en détail
pour ce qui est du dow jones de la
bourse de new york progression de 2
8 pour ça le s p500 augmentation de 2,7
pour cent depuis l'ouverture ce matin
nasdaq augmentation de 3,8 pour ça et
finalement pour le tsx hausse de 1,1
pour cent alors les certains économistes
le disent il faudra s'habituer à une
plus grande volatilité au cours des
prochains mois peut-être pour l'année
2010 9 c'est à dire des hausses et des
baisses plus marquées alors si ce qu'on
a pu constater depuis hier et merci pour
ce portrait olivier d'avoir appris